back here in the US and America's
election headquarters tonight
Republicans breathe a sigh of relief in
West Virginia the administration's
effort to block a Republican Senate
candidate in that state succeeded last
night correspondent Peter Doocy has that
story in a roundup of the evenings other
elections from West Virginia the so
called swamp was nearly swept last night
and I was taught my whole life that a
kid no excuses anti-establishment
electorates denied three Republican
members of Congress their bids for
higher office and one Republican member
the chance to run for re-election but
Mitch McConnell is happy because West
Virginia's don blankenship the candidate
his allies we're sure couldn't win in
November who coined the nickname cocaine
Mitch came in third don't feel sorry for
me the majority leader gloated with a
Pablo Escobar's inspired parody of the
Netflix show narcos where a cocaine
covered McConnell appears next to the
message thanks for playing
Don I'm glad the people of West Virginia
decided that particular approach of
attacking me and my family was good for
a distant third place but McConnell
isn't the one West Virginia's winner
Attorney General Patrick Morrissey is
thanking mr. president if you're
watching right now let me tell you your
tweet was huge it wasn't a huge night
for House members though congressman
Evan Jenkins was the runner up in West
Virginia congressman Robert Pittenger
lost in North Carolina so can't defend
his seat and congressman Luke Messer and
congressman Todd Rokita were casualties
in Indiana where a lesser known
businessman Mike Braun will challenge
incumbent Senator Joe Donnelly with the
campaign modeled on president Trump's
when I saw him clear the field back in
16
I thought well maybe we can get more of
us in the Senate a trump-like message
was also critical in helping Congressman
Jim Renee C become the only GOP House
member to advance he now faces
Democratic senator sherrod Brown Al
Hayat Democrat Richard Cordray and Obama
alumni and a favorite of senator
Elizabeth Warren easily beat Dennis
Kucinich for a chance to succeed
Governor John Kasich you demanded change
and we heard you and we want the same
with the exception of California's
upcoming primary where Democratic
Senator Dianne Feinstein failed to
secure her party's endorsement in the
midst of a progressive challenge from
state senator Kevin de Leon the
Democrats Senate field is mostly set so
they're preserving resources to face a
roster of Republicans still being filled
in every candidate that we wanted one
Republican candidates had been competing
to be the most like Trump now the last
ones standing are competing for spots on
his calendar they all think a Trump
rally in a state that he won would help
send them to Washington Brett
Peter Doocy in West Virginia Peter thank
you